So let’s follow our Jersey Square team and
see what they did with customer segments.
Now, what happened is, they got out of the
building and this time, after they spoke to
a series of customers, they spoke to over 60.
And what they found out was what they
originally thought was a single customer
segment actually turned out to be there
were two separate segments. It turned out
there were the original segment they thought,
rabid sports jersey owners, who were male,
13 to 35, who passionately followed their
team and went to a lot of games. But there
were also people who casually attended
games. Male and female and they kind of
were closer to 18-30 and they were casual fans.
So number one, as you can now see that
there are not only two customer segments,
but there are two value propositions, that is,
there is a value proposition that matches
each one of the segments and there’s a
revenue stream that matches each one of the
segments. And so now you could kind of
see the power of the canvass. This is a
multi-sided market. You have at least two
customers segments and you have two
value props and attending revenue streams.
Now you should notice what the Jersey
Square team did wonderfully, they actually
started with the archetype. The archetype
though, if you remember is, kind of the end
result of understanding the pain and the
gain we were solving with the value
proposition. So they really were missing
talking about gains and pains over here as well.
And it would have been great if they had
that added in, but a pretty good job in
trying to understand what their archetype
was which need to match their
minimum viable product over here.